hey what's up guys it's rob and welcome
to my tutorial for
the ninja star boomerang i spoke with
jeremy shafer about trying to come up
with a ninja star that comes back and
while each of us were trying to figure
it out we both came up with our own
designs mine is made from half a sheet
of printer paper and flies like this
[Music]
while jeremy's is made from four origami
squares and flies just like this
i'll have a link to his tutorial at the
end of the video so be sure to check it
out i'm really happy and proud of the
ninja star boomerang because it's not
only easy to make but it flies
incredibly well better than any
boomerang that i've made and it's
quickly become my favorite thing to make
you're going to want to show it off to
all your friends so be sure to give it a
thumbs up down below if you do enjoy the
video so grab your piece of paper and
let's make it for the tutorial we're
going to need half a sheet of letter
size printer paper just like this which
will then split up again into quarters
and make two identical pieces which will
then fit together and interlock just
like the ninja stars do i highly
recommend you first try with a plain
white sheet because although it looks a
little nicer with the colored paper i
found that the white is a little bit
thinner and winds up flying much better
we can first fold the paper in half by
taking the top and aligning it with the
bottom and once it's lined up neatly we
can make a nice sharp crease along the
top with our fingernail by running it
across a couple times and you can either
cut it or as i prefer to do just tear it
right in half
to split the paper into quarters we can
do the same exact thing by folding the
paper in half and meeting the edges
together neatly then we can make a nice
sharp crease along the top and just
carefully rip the paper in half
now that we have the paper in quarters
like we need we can go on to make the
two units and interlock them so just set
one of the pieces aside
and then we're going to take the quarter
and we're going to fold it in half so
just align the edges together
once it's neatly aligned just make a
crease all throughout the paper
and just give it a nice sharp crease on
top
now we can take the left side and fold
it across to the right side
line up the two ends
and just give it a hold here on the
right and a tug in the middle and crease
it on the left side
just run your fingernail against it once
and then you could open it up so that
it's a mountain fold and that the open
edges are on the bottom
set it down and i'm just going to mark
it so that you can see it a little
easier here
now we can take the right side and we're
just going to take this top edge and
fold it down onto that vertical line
give it a nice crease here
and on the left side we're just going to
do the opposite so we're going to take
the bottom and fold it up
once we do that we can then crease on
that new fold
so you should have something like this
and we're just going to flip it over
and just make sure that it's nice and
flat
these next folds we're going to make are
important because it's going to
establish the flap or the sort of little
airfoil that we have here on each of the
wings or arms the boomerang that help it
fly in that nice circle we're going to
fold this top edge down to the bottom
just like this
except we're not going to fold it all
the way we're going to leave a little
bit of space and as you'll see here i've
made a mark and that mark is 1 8 of an
inch from the bottom
and i'm giving you a measurement because
i think you should probably try it the
first time you make it just so you have
an idea of about how much that is and as
you'll see here on the ruler an eighth
of an inch is just basically that first
big increment that we have right here
now that you know what to do we're going
to take the edge and we're just going to
fold it like this and as you'll see the
whole left side comes along and i'm just
going to basically line it up with that
line that i drew
so this whole left side should kind of
flip and i'm going to line it up all the
way across and then make a nice sharp
crease
now i'm going to just run my fingernail
against the top
now we're going to do the same on the
other side so all we need to do is to
flip it upside down like this
and then we're going to take this edge
right here
and we're going to fold it down as well
leaving a little bit of space about an
eighth of an inch i'm going to eyeball
this time but if you want to draw the
line from the bottom you can just take
it
and fold it down like this
leaving a little bit of space
and make sure that it's parallel all the
way across
once you have it pretty even all the way
on the bottom
then you can make that crease on top
and just give it a nice good crease and
make sure that you didn't kind of pull
these apart so it should look something
like this
now that we made those folds you'll see
on the front here i have a diamond that
i'm holding facing towards me whereas on
the back it's split where we folded
those two edges and i'm going to
basically take the ends here and i'm
just going to hold them like this with
the corners facing towards me i'm going
to open them now i'm going to airplane
both of the corners into this vertical
line just like this so just fold it
directly on that vertical line here
and make a crease and then do the same
on the left side as you'll see because
the left side is thinner it makes a
smaller triangle but we both want these
top edges directly on the middle just
like that
then you can re-close the two edges
together
and just pinch it and make a crease
do the same on the other side just hold
it like this open it up and just
airplane these corners
directly onto the center
and then reclose it
so it should look something like this
now all we need to do now is basically
just fold these arms in a little bit
it's not critically important where it
is usually right around this little
point or corner that you see right here
so i'm just going to take it and just
fold it like this and you'll feel some
resistance so right when you feel some
resistance right around there is good
and we're just going to make sure that
this outside edge is aligned with this
one on the bottom
so once they're lined up like this
then you can just give it a good pinch
then you can unfold it
and you can do the same with the left
side so just take it like this
and just lift it up and fold it across
and when you feel some resistance right
around this corner here then all you
need to do is just line it up and just
give it a pinch and there you go that's
how to make one of the pieces
now that we've finished the first piece
the second piece is made the same exact
way so if you need to you can re-watch
the time that i've listed below and when
you're done we're ready to interlock the
two pieces together all right guys all
that's left now is to interlock the two
pieces together and as you'll see i'm
holding them so that the diamonds are
facing me on the right side i drew a
line from the top of the diamond to the
bottom and on the left side i drew one
from the left to the right and we're
basically just going to take the one on
the right and turn it 90 degrees and put
it on top of the one on the left and if
you can see you're just going to
basically overlap the diamonds by kind
of putting them right in the middle and
sort of overlapping the lines just like
that so right around there is good
i'm going to start with the top arm and
we're going to fold it down and we're
going to go in a clockwise direction so
that's one then we go here
that's two and you can move these around
if you need to because they are going to
start overlapping so here we go this is
three
and as you'll see if it gets a little
scrunched up then you just can move move
it around like this shift this down
the last one here is going to go over
this one the third one and underneath
the first one kind of under here so what
i'm going to do is hold it here and i'm
going to lift up the first one by just
pulling it out like this
i'm going to pinch it right here and i'm
going to take the last arm and just
round it off a little bit and then i'm
going to stick the point right into that
opening right there
and i'm going to pull it through now
when you pull these through you want to
make sure that they go up to the folds
that you kind of created before so you
want to re-tuck the first one that you
pulled out
just like this
kind of push it in
while you're pushing in the other ones
like this
and make sure that it's nice and flat in
the middle so just kind of you can kind
of tug on the opposite ones a little bit
like this
and there you go you'll see it will come
together sort of like that so just make
sure it's nice and flat in the middle
once you get it all interlocked
and then all we need to do is we're
going to basically take this little
overlapped this little flap and we're
going to fold it right along this edge
so just take it and fold it right all
the way down i'm going to set it down on
the table because it's a little easier
for me i'm just going to take the edge
and fold it all the way down on there as
you'll notice when you do that it
doesn't want to fold in the corner here
that's okay you just got to leave it a
little bit curved all right so just
press it like that right in the corner
then just rotate it fold this one down
now all the way
then the next one
fold it down
and just walk my finger up
right there
and then finally we'll do the last one
and there you go there is your ninja
star boomerang now what i like to do is
to just run my fingernail over all of
the creases especially these right here
you want to make sure it's nice and flat
so just press it down like this
upside down
and you're ready to throw it i'm going
to hold the boomerang so that the four
interlocked boxes are facing the left
side with the air foils and my pointer
and middle finger are grabbing one of
the arms just like this close to the end
alright and i'm going to rest the other
arm of the boomerang on my palm right
near my thumb like this
and i'm going to basically curl my wrist
and i'm going to
flick it out like that like i would with
a yo-yo you could do it directly out but
i also recommend you could do it up like
this at like a 20 or 30 degree angle all
right so i'm just going to basically go
like this and flick my wrist really hard
and release the boomerang okay
so let's give it a shot
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching my
tutorial for my all new ninja star
boomerang design if you did like it
don't forget to give it a thumbs up down
below and if you're not already
subscribed click that subscribe and
notification bell so that you know when
i come out with a new video to check out
jeremy's tutorial for his boomerang you
can click this little card here in the
upper right and i'll place the link in
the video description below after you
throw the ninja star boomerang a couple
times you might notice it starts to get
a little bent or it might not come back
as well what you need to do after every
couple throws is just flatten it out and
reinforce the creases to make it fly
great again if you find when you throw
the boomerang that it hits the ground or
it doesn't come back all the way or even
if it shoots off in the other direction
what you can do is hold these four boxes
on the bottom and tilt the wings up like
this ever so slightly and you should
notice that the boomerang will come back
a little better with some practice
throwing and catching it you'll
definitely become a ninja star boomerang
pro in no time as always thanks so much
for the support and i'll see you soon
put your leg down
how are you for
hey what's up hey
hey what's up guys it's
hey what's up guys it's rob and welcome
to my tutorial for
[Laughter]
come on